Hello everybody, My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica-
I just had the scariest moment in all my time in Subnautica.
I was trying to load my save over in the experimental build, I am now in the stable build - I'll tell you why in just a moment
I was trying to load up my save and it would not load.
It would hang and then the game would crash and then I tried that again.
I went back to stable, I went back to experimental, I - I edited my save file information,
I deleted files in my save. I copied it obviously; did a backup of it.
And I was about ready to give up. I was about ready to Until Dawn this shit and start over,
and I was committed. I- I even recorded a bit where I was showing you guys that it crashed,
and I was going on this big long rambling speech about how I was gonna take the long way around
because it was what it felt was right.
'Cause I didn't want to cheat. I did not want to cheat- even if I had to start over again and play for twenty more hours
Just to get back to this point here, I was about to do that.
And then I- then I looked up just one more thing and that was changing the- the uh, the- the- the date, the build date
in my save file and going back to the stable version and trying to load it up there.
And it worked and I'm here, and I'm here and it worked and I don't have to waste twenty hours of my life..
Getting back to this point here.
So, that catches you up on the hell that I've just been through for the past hour and a half
So lets get back to the game, shall we?
Alright,
so I know for a fact that the next alien facility is not open yet.
It's not available, it does not exist in the game.
The outside does, and we'll go see that in a bit, I believe its way, way, way, deep down-
but we'll see that in a bit.
But for right now we gotta explore the-
-the very last remnants of what's in here because we have a blue alien artifact.
And I imagine...
My theory is that the blue alien artifact is probably what's going to open the Primary Research Facility,
which is the deepest facility in the whole alien spectrum of facilities.
This is the Thermal Power Plant which powers everything..
That the aliens have, use, create, even the Warpers, this place powers it all through wireless energy
And that's a really cool concept, I mean it's not totally formed I think I've mentioned before
But...
Super cool idea that it's all powered in one hub.
Now if there's a way, I don't know if any of you guys told me-
I got comments from last time, I'll read them in just a second.
But, uh, I- I don't know...
If there's, um, no way to get that portal in this place open.
Because that is a portal, that is one of the gateways,
but I just don't know if it ties back to a gateway in another location.
And if it does, that might mean I have to activate it from there first-
But that doesn't make a lot of sense, because why would you have a cheat way just to go down..
It makes more sense if you have a way to go back up.
So, I'm gonna get back in Mr. Fister who rose from the dead.
*Mumbling* My hands, ok, there we go. That's good.
Alright, so, I'm gonna explore the rest of this place and hopefully find some more secrets about this
and maybe find a way to activate...
Y'know...
That whole deal. Wow, this ceiling's a lot lower than I remember it being.
In fact, this whole place seems slightly different than I remember it being..
But then again, it might just be the horrors that I experienced just a little bit ago.
So,
This is a gateway.
I've seen this before, I know this before.
This is definitely a gateway, so if there's a way to activate it, it's gotta be in here...
It would have to be in here, there's-
-there's definitely not gonna be anything else around
Ah, ok, so right here- I had to look it up, I was, I was looking around the room for a bit
and then I just wanted to make sure it was possible
In the future plan section it says:
"The Precursor Teleporter in the Thermal Power Generator will be hooked up to the teleporter in the Quarantine Enforcement Platform."
Which is the big ass gun that shoots down absolutely everything that tries to get in the planet, so...
We're going to...
Just leave that lie for now,
It would be super awesome to be able to zip back up to the top knowing that I could go right to that place
I could even have a casual beach side base on that island right by my big ass gun..
..After I reprogram it for my purposes and not just shoot me as I try to leave
And then I could be King of this planet that I hate!
Oh! I could be Lord of the Oceans that I'm terrified of!
Wouldn't that be just wonderful? Oh, I can't thrust when I'm not in water.
I don't know why I thought I would be able to.
But anyway, I've got some comments here that I- I- I mean to read
First one is George East, uh, who said:
"Markiplier episode 1: I HATE THE OCEAN I HATE THE OCEAN I HATE THE OCEAN!!!
And then:
"Markisa- Markiplier now: *Rams Sea Dragon with submarine*"
Oh man, if that doesn't put into perspective what the-
-the changes that I've been through in this horror show that is Subnautica then, I don't know what will.
So, now that I've gone in here I- *Roaring*
Ugh, that dragon is ACTIVE!
So I don't know if there's anything else in this area to explore...
There was that cave where I blew up the floor but I don't know if that actually leads anywhere
But I might as well check it out before I go, uh, deeper in.
ooh, Oh! Is- oh it must lead up to another entrance in here.
At least that's what I think it would do.
*confused noises*
Hoba-dobie.
Hobodo- Okay, there we go.
Oh where do you lead?
Please tell me you lead out and not to another horrible monstrosity that I don't wanna face.
(tense music)
Ah, God the music is so nice.
Uh, can I please get back to Big Box Barry?
I don't feel safe out by myself.
Aw I'm getting farther away from him.
Where am I going?
Ohhhh what is this?
Hello! Schka-doosky!
Get me up you. Am I thrusting? I can't tell.
Heur-duer--!
OH, okay it's another way in.
Okay good.
Alright, so where, oh where-- ewwuh-uh, is this Sea Dragon?
Sea Dragon's gotta be around.
*roar in distence* Ewuh....
Okay.
Alright just gotta make it back to Mr. Fister, and I think--
WOAH HEY YOURE CLO- ooooh okay I'm gonna save now!
Alright, you wanna go bruh? Huh? You wanna go? I'll go..
Apparently, no I wont, I wo-- there we go.
Alright, You wanna go? Huh? Alright, fine.
You wanna be like that? I'll go with you.
I'll go a few places.
We'll go-- I'll go mono-e-mono with you.
Yeah? I just clawed my way back from the death, bitch.
I had a tough time, thought my save wasn't gonna load.
Thought i was gonna have to fight 20 hours to get back to you, which I was gonna.
Ooooohhhhh, hey.
Alright you wanna fight? Oh, I've got a plan for you.
If it worked for the Warper, it might work for you!
Missed? Okay, missed, missed, missed gotta go back now.
Gotta go-- *yelling* Get me back! Get me back!
Uh get me back, get me back, getmeback, get-me-back.
Ohhh get me back. Okay.
Where'd he go?
Oh he's way over there.
Well that's ominous and scary looking.
Okay.
You wanna come back here buddy?
Hey.
I'm gonna grind the shit out of you.
I'm gonna gr- Woah, hey that's scary.
Alright- I'm gonna grind the shit outta you!
Aw fuck he cant grab on to him!
Oh okay. He's got-
He's- he's intangible.
You can't actually touch him.
Oh boy.
That's terrifying..
Okay, so is he gonna pop out of the mountain and just grab me up in one gulp?
Yeah I'm gonna do this, I know I'm stupid.
Also, Able Turwulisere:
"Mark: this area terrifies me and scares the shit out of me, I'm most likely gonna die. I'm gonna -- I'm gonna live here."
"Rest in peace, Mark, rest in piece."
Oh shit -
Alright. And then Zephyr Zerorium said something similar : "Bad idea to build a base where the sea dragon lives."
"There might be a 5.2% chance that the dragon might see your base of yours and destroy it."
"Of course the thermal reactor is handy down there, and heat resistance too,"
"but still, it's a bad idea!" Just like trying to beat the shit out of this fuckin' dragon.
With my bare hands.
Or, my bare Mr. Fister hands.
[dragon roars in the background]
My bare.. Fisters.
Awwww yeah.
Ugh, you scream a lot -- get off me!
Jesus, you're tough.
I bet the Sea Dragon is gonna be tough too.
But that's alright.
I'm just trying to make my way back.
To my, uh..
Base...
At this point.
Oh boy, okay.
Ah shit.
Right next to 'em-- ah no you don't no, no, no.
Okay,
I'm almost back in.
Oh shit,  oh God.
Ah-- oh fuck.
Oh I thought-- *yelling* Hey, heyo-- fuck!
You wanna go?!
Oh, I got him!
I-I got him?
Oh shit.
Do I got him?
I don't know if I got him.
I don't know where I'm going.
Oh God, I think I got him.
Holy shit, holy shit.
Oh my god!
Get- get ground, bitch!
Oh fuck.
Oh, this is a bad idea.
Oh my God.
Oh I have no idea what's happening right now.
The game doesn't even know how to handle it.
Holy shit.
I got him.
Uhh- I lost some health.
Oh, man. I'm being skated around on the ground.
Huh, fuck dude. Holy shit!
Oh fuck! Oh why am I doing this?
Oh god! Well shit. Here we go.
Fuck. He's trying to get me. Oh god.
Oh god I'm grinding him.
Holy shit balls. I'm not going to let go.
Think I'm going to let go? Huh? After I caught this big fish?
This real big fish? [dragon roaring]
Oh my God.
Holy fuck.
Okay ca- I don't even know. He's just going to drag me into the wall there.
Alright if I could just make a few passes on this. Agh.
Barely contact.
Shit dude.
Oh boy.
Oh boy, this is a terrible idea.
Oh this is the worst idea I have ever had. How far away am I from my-
Oh good I'm not too far away.
Heyyo hey watch those fireballs there buddy.
Get you. Get you. Get you. Get you. Get you. Get you. Yeah! Yeah, you want some?
You can't handle me. Ehh. Do I sound confident?
Oh fuck. Oh my God.
Oh my God. He's hitting me somehow.
I think it's his fins.
Just me bouncing off of his fins is damaging me.
Uh. Unless it's just all the residual heat from all of the lava rocks that he swallowed, which is--
that's how he's able to spit 'em, if you didn't know, fun fact about the Sea Dragon.
Oh shit dude.
Fuck.
I feel like Captain Ahab.
Shit.
Ugh, grind.. Grind it.
Grind it, grind it, grind it--Woah hey whoa whoa whoa, what's happening? Where am I?
Whoaa where am I?
I think he tried to eat me. Holy shit!
Fuck, I was in his mouth for a second there. Ok grind-grind-grind-grind, get-ground-get-ground-getground--
Get ground *gasp* Whoa! Aww I thought I killed him for a second there, ohh, ok.
*Sea Dragon roars* Ah shit- *continues to roar* Who's gonna die first, me or him?
Augh! Oh god, that's in the mouth, that is definitely in the mouth.
Holy shit.
Oh my God.
Can you kill him? I have no idea.
I gotta go back for repairs soon, if I can go back at all.
Ah shit! Gotta go back for repairs and water.
Fuuck.
Holy shit.
Ok. Alright, one last pass and then I'm gonna get outta here.
If I can't kill him now, I don't think I ever will.
Fuck. God, he keeps tossing me away so far.
Ah you know what I'm gonna bail. I'm at 19%, oh f-- I am drifting very far.
Do not come back for me. I think we did.. Equal damage to both of us.
Fuck.
That was terrifying.
Holy shit get me back to Big Box Barry please.
Welcome me in the bosom.
Ah fuck! Ran outta--
Ah shit.
Ugh.
God damn it that was terrifying.
Yeeeeop!
*grappler attaches* Yes! Ok. Let me back in please!
Sheeseums...
Get back in. Lil more, lil more, lil more--Come on!
Please! I'm right here- come ooon!
*grunts* Theeere, okay there we go! Hoooly shit!
Holy shit.
*sigh of relief*
Ohh my God.
That was a harrowing adventure.
*whispers* Fuck, dude.
Ugh that's not okay.
That is all kinds of not okay... Hoh boy.
Let me just save here.
Hoh man..
*sigh of relief*
Why did I do that..
..Why did I do that..
I have no idea why I did that. *louder* I have no idea why I did that.
I have no god damn idea.
I have NO idea.
Fuck, alright.
So, getting my bearings..
Getting a drink of water..
*Mark having a sippy-sippy*
That was terrifying.
But anyway.. So I've one more comment to read.
Thank you Kim Song-soo who gave a huge list of stuff for me from notifying me
which video wasn't in my playlist to talking about thermometers, uh..
You can pick up pink floaters and you can release them near other creatures and
they will home in on them and take them away, so I'm wondering what'll happen if
I get enough floaters and attach it to the Sea Dragon, or any other creature.
Ah man, and then talking about a whole bunch of other stuff, things that I've missed in the past, little tips.
I've pinned that comment to the last uh,
to the last umm, la-last video that I did and in the future,
Every comment that I get I'm just gonna pin,
Uh, so that those who--if I can't build a, frickin locker, then I'm gonna be able to
Uhhm, at least recognize those comments in some way.
So, that'll be the future. I'll still make lockers when I can and have the titanium for them,
but if I can't, I'll pin the comments.
*tired exhale* Ok alright I'm good.
I'm good guys, I'm good.
So, long story short, there's no titanium down here, and I've already committed to not cheating
so I'm not gonna be able to build a base right now.
That doesn't mean that I won't try to do that in the future, it just means that if I were to do that
I will have to bring down an umpteen million amount of titanium and all the other building materials that I'm gonna need..
..and that's gonna take a while. But, hopefully it'll be worth it.
I'm not ending this episode, I don't know why I'm standing just still here
Oh god damn it Larry C--or Lester, get off my god damn boat
Stop draining my frickin power like that.
Ugh get off, get off get off ge--I know I probably got more elsewhere
Ow! That hurts. A lot. Oh, he sounds close.
Alright.
I'm just checking to see if there's more because I could've sworn I remember seeing one.
Nah, we're good, okay
Ehh, ehh, he's unhappy
Ah we got one floating in, we gotta move, get outta here!
Lester's comin' back!
Heurrr- okay we're outta here, okay.
So we're gonna get outta here, and what we're gonna do is we're gonna try to find...
Where the uh, the alien containment is
Or, or a way out, whichever way we go first 'cause I have no idea where we are in relation to where we were.
So I'm just gonna pick a direction, go that way, and hopefully..
I don't know, hopefully reach something that I need soon. *sighs* Frick.
I'm not okay.
I don't know why I'm not okay after that, I mean,
in all honesty.. I don't know, that was just,
that was just really stupid of me to do, but also frickin awesome to be able to do.
I didn't even know if that was gonna work, and uh,
I'd given up on it and then all of a sudden he pops outta nowhere and I attach onto hi-- ohh my God he's after me!
Ohhoo hi!
Oh he's mad, he wants round two.
Oh frick dude, I'll ram you with the Sea Moth--
Er the Cyclops--
Big Box Barry gonna slam into you and you not gonna like it.
I don't know if that's gonna hurt you at all
I don't know, I don't even know if it can be killed
Can it? Do you guys know? Do you guys know if the Sea Dragon can be killed? Because,
I bet, if it's able to beat the shit out of an entire alien containment facility...
And then that's what kills it, through only severe head trauma and only after
it brings down the whole facility.. Like, what am I gonna do to it?
What am I gonna do, ramming into that thing?
Very little, that's for sure.
Ok, but anyway,
I'm good, we're all good. I'm calm, we're gettin' back into it, we're making a nice, relaxing, beeline, tail-between-our-legs sprint outta here,
and then we're going in finding something else- or maybe not because where the heck is this?
Ok, that might be the way I came in or it might be... the way deeper in, I have no idea.
So I'm just gonna venture down this way,
Try to see if I can drop lower.
I think this might be the way I came in from..
I don't know though.
Geeez.
It's all a frickin mystery down here and I can't see anything with all this frickin blue!
*quietly* Ooh, ooh, oh, ohhh.
I don't like the look of that.
I don't like the look of it but,
I'm gonna explore.
I'm gonna repair Mr. Fister
Oh no I don't have batteries, God damn it I need to put-
I need to put my batteries in there!
Aw I need to make a battery! Okay, hang on.
Uh I got the recipe for uh, making...
Oh I just need copper?
Is that all I need?
That's amazing!
I'll have a perma-battery, I've got copper!
I've got lots of copper!
Ohh okay, alright good, ah.
Alright, so if I make-- eugh, fuck-- If I make- I don't know why I'm still flustered..
If I make an ion battery, and then--I don't have silicone because I'm pretty sure to make silicone you need
either the creep vine something, I forget what they've changed it to recently.
Uh, yeah you need seed clusters, so I don't have that down here, um, but, I can at least make the battery.
I can make 2 of those, and then I'll be able to power--
actually, I need one for pretty much everything I have.
How many ion crystals do I have to spare in total? Oh I've got a lot! Ok, I'm gonna put these all in one location.
I'm not gonna use 'em all, obviously, but the ideal is to turn
all the battery-powered devices that I have into batteries,
and at least save six of those for my Cyclops to
eventually change out the power cells into ion cells.
Which would be the ideal, 'cuz that would - that would help out the most.
But this is at low battery, so if I just pop that in there...
And then I'm pretty sure that these are all gonna be -
uh... These are all gonna be - I'm gonna make one more for my builder - these are all gonna be...
Good, in terms of... Like, lasting longer-
and also they can be recharged.
I'm pretty sure. I'm not a hundred percent sure on that,
but I - I would be surprised if you couldn't recharge these
incredibly valuable, very rare, ion batteries.
So I'm just gonna do that...
Ah, no - come on - come on, now.
Oh, apparently the builder can't use the ion power source.
Oh, that's bizarre.
Huh.
Maybe the scanner can? No. Why's that?
This can. Yeah. Oh, that's bizarre.
I guess only the high-powered things can.
Ooh! That means I can finally make a SeaGlide again and it can not suck!
Oh, I can go back and get my SeaGlide! If I ever get out of this hell hole.
But...that's, that's good.
Oh, okay. Alright, anyway, so I'll stop freaking out about that.
So I've got - I'll put all the ion stuff in one storage,
Uh, Jonas Grav will have that.
SoWasRed has miscellaneous stuff...
Common coral, for.. Water, which I don't need right now.
I can just eat some fruit, I think.
Okay--
so let's repair you.
With my super power.
Oh man that goes down real slow-- Hey!
Fucking hey!
Hey-- God damn it, get off him!
Get off of 'em!
Don't you dare, don't you dare.
Don't you dare.
I'm repairing him, he needs a break.
Just give him a God damn breather.
Okay.
So anyway,
So I'm gonna take this thing down, I don't even know if there's a hole down there to really go deep into,
so I'm just assuming that this is a..
This is just a normal.. Not too terrible hole.
Yeah.
But I just kinda wanna explore and also take an oppurtunity to repair-
also, it's not that hot down here- why is it not..?
..Roastingly hot?
'Cause that's normally a thing that happens when I'm..
When I'm, uh..
Down here, I'm usually dying from the heat, but apparently right now I am not.
And I don't when that happened.
I mean, I haven't modified my suit..
So this just must be..
Generally a colder area? Oh, there's mushrooms down here.
Well that's weird.
Where the hell am I?
Why are there mushrooms down here?
Are there other materials down here..?
Oh God damn it! Lester, get off my God damn boat!
And that might explain why it's cooler over here.. 'Cause it is going towards the..
The cooler location.
Okay, yeah, this is definitely going up, okay.
So this is the way I came.
One hundred percent, because I think it's just- that's where it just goes straight up
and..
So that means I can go back down--
and that explains why the mushrooms are there, so the mushrooms are like,
a transitional thing between this and the Lost River...
At least that tree area.
So if I go this way and then go straight across, to the other side of where the..
The uh, the Thermal Generator Power Plant is,
then hopefully, I'll find another way to go even deeper.
It might be in that cave, it might be through that cave- I'm not 100% sure
that that cave.. *Laughs weakly* Didn't lead deeper-
I just didn't get a chance to explore it because Mr. Fister was about to die, and then Mr. Fister did die, and then...
*random beep in-game*
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck was that..?
*soft chuckling of confusion*
*quietly* I hate the ocean so much.
Fuck, that guy is really draining my power.
Uhhh--
fine.
Fine, fine fine, I'm gonna get him off.
Fine fine fine fine fine fine fine fine!
Hey, c'mon.
Oh God, I've got a lot of them on here.
Get off!
Ge- oh my God!
It's 'cause I'm just sitting there repairing?
Get off!
Get off- hey--
Fuck you.
Get off.
Geeet off.
Anymore of you assholes on there--? There's so many!
Get off my boat!
God damn it stop!
Ah- I hit you once!
Where'd you go?
Oh there we go, okay, get off- yeah, get off.
Okay, I hope none of them got back on after I beat 'em off.
Let's just get out of here-- *in-game squeak*
Goddamn it! That was the sound of you snatchin' on there, isn't it?
Fucking hell.
These fucking assholes! Stop it!
Stop it!
You frickin' assholes, they just pop right back on!
Get off. there we go, get off, I'll kill you.
Alright, lemme just go before I..
'Cause I can't- I can't just-- oh God they're right back on.
Frick a dick. Frick you and frick a dick.
Oh, man, this is an issue.
Okay, there's the plant.. Okay.
So then...
That might actually mean they're just straight across where it was-- the cave.
And if that was where the cave was, then maybe the cave is in fact where I'm supposed to go.
Was that- that is it. That's it, that's it right there.
Tight corners in here..
Reeeal tight.
This might actually not be cave at all, this might just be..
A formation that looks cave-like.
Ah, shit.
I ignored my booping warnings.
Yeah, this might not be a cave, this might just be some archways that seem to lead me down...
A bit farther.
Yeah- woah.
Yeah.
Yeah this is.. This isn't that I was looking for.
God, how am I gonna back outta here?
Maybe I can just get out this way-- Euhhhh- it's too small.
I can't fit!
Frick!
Awh shit, aw God damn it, okay.
Alright, we're fine. Okay..
So anyway this wasn't where I was supposed to go, uh...
So I'll figure out where to go in the next episode I have, uh...
I've gotten myself in some trouble, and I've gotten myself out of some trouble.
And uh, all I need to know
is there the hell I'm going next.
So I'm gonna find that very soon.
I'll have more updates as we go, and then eventually long-term plans: build a base down here,
fight the Sea Dragon...
Kinda like- it will be a Captain Ahab-
type situation.
With my white whale that I'm going to.. Beat to death.
...With my bare Mr. Fister.
But we'll see when that happens.
So thank you everybody so much for watching,
let me know how I'm doing in the comments below and give me some advice or encouragement, or..
Make a joke..
That's all I really need to know about.
Thanks again.
And as always; I will see you in the next video.
Buh-bye!
[outro]